>> Tucker: THAT WOULD BE
SHOCKING.
THANK YOU BOTH.
I HOPE YOU GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THOSE.
TED MALIK WAS AN INFORMER
ADVISOR TO THE DONALD TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IN MARCH HE SAYS HE WAS DETAINED
AT AN AIRPORT BY INVESTIGATORS
FOR ROBERT MUELLER WHO TOOK AWAY
HIS CELL PHONE AND ASKED ABOUT
HIS TIES TO ROGER STONE AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
HE IS ALSO THE AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK "THE PLOT TO DESTROY TRUMP"
ABOUT THE DEEP STATE.
GIFFORD COMING ON.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU SAY YOU
WERE DETAINED, THAT'S KIND OF A
REMARKABLE STORY.
TELL US THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THIS.
>> ESPECIALLY FOR YALE, OXFORD
BUSINESS PROFESSOR TO BE STOPPED
AT AN AIRPORT, TAKEN INTO A ROOM
AND ASK QUESTIONS BY THE FBI AND
HAVING THEIR PHONE UNDER A
WARRANT SEIZED.
I WRITE ABOUT THIS IN THE BOOK
AS A POSTSCRIPT AND MY LAWYERS
TELL ME NOT TO CONFIRM OR DENY
VERY MUCH ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I'M
STILL ACTIVELY PARTICIPATING IN
THIS CONVERSATION.
>> Tucker: I DON'T UNDERSTAND,
WHY WOULD THAT PUT YOU WITH
LEGAL PERIL IF YOU BELIEVE THE
GOVERNMENT OVERSTEPPED AND
DETAINED YOU -- THE LOGAN
AIRPORT IN BOSTON, RIGHT?
FLYING IN FROM ABROAD.
THEY PULL YOU ASIDE, TAKE YOUR
CELL PHONE AND ASK YOU
QUESTIONS.
YOU HAVE NO LAWYER PRESENT, IS
THAT CORRECT, DURING THIS
CONVERSATION?
>> NONE AT ALL.
>> Tucker: SO HOW -- WHY WOULD
YOU BE IN JEOPARDY BY EXERCISING
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
EXPLAIN THE TRUTH?
>> I HAVE EXPLAINED IT AS A
POSTSCRIPT TO THE BOOK AND
ACTUALLY DETAILED IT AND I'M
TOLD THAT THE FBI IS NOT ALL
THAT HAPPY ABOUT THAT FACT.
THEREFORE, I'M NOT REALLY AT
LIBERTY TO SAY A WHOLE LOT MORE
ABOUT WHERE THIS STANDS AT
PRESENT.
>> Tucker: GIVE US A SENSE,
WHEN YOU SAT DOWN YOU HAD NO
LAWYER.
IT'S GENERALLY NOT ADVISED TO
TALK TO THE FBI WITHOUT A
LAWYER.
DID THEY JUST GRAB YOU IF YOU
GOT OFF THE PLANE?
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO THEM WHEN
THEY DID?
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2I
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2U
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2E
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2,
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2A
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2S
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2I
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2Y
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2A
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2D
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2T
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2E
>> THEY HAD TO WAIT FOR ABOUT 2N
DIVIDED ME FROM MY WIFE AND THEN
SEARCHED MY BELONGINGS AND TOOK
ME TO A SEPARATE BUILDING TO
INTRODUCE ME TO TWO FBI AGENTS
WHO ASKED ME A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS.
ACTUALLY IT WAS QUITE CHIT
CHATTY FOR ABOUT 20 MINUTES.
AS A FAN OF THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES THEY ASKED
ME WHAT I THOUGHT OF THEIR
VICTORY AT THE SUPER BOWL.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHAT THEY
SAID TO MIKE FLYNN DURING HIS
CHIT CHATTY CONVERSATION.
THEY HAD A WARRANT FOR ALL OF
THIS, I ASSUME, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> CORRECT.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
WHAT DID THEY ASK YOU?
>> AS I SAID IN THE POSTSCRIPT,
THERE WERE VERY FEW SUBSTANTIVE
QUESTIONS.
SOME ABOUT INDIVIDUALS, WHAT MY
RELATIONSHIP WASN'T TO THE
CAMPAIGN.
THEY SEEM TO KNOW ALL THE
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS.
>> Tucker: DID YOU CONSIDER
SAYING BUZZ OFF, I'M NOT GOING
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS?
>> I THINK HAD THEY GOTTEN ANY
MORE AGGRESSIVE THAN IN FACT
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE CASE,
BUT THEY WERE FAIRLY BENIGN.
I'M A PATRIOTIC AMERICAN.
A COLD WAR ERA.
I WORKED IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
I WAS THE TOP AMERICAN IN THE
U.N. IN GENEVA, SWITZERLAND, FOR
FOUR YEARS AT THE END OF THE
COLD WAR.
I'M CERTAINLY WILLING TO
COOPERATE IN ANY INQUIRY.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE MUCH TO
ADD.
>> Tucker: WHY DO YOU THINK
THEY WANTED TO TALK TO YOU?
>> MY PUBLISHER THINKS THAT THEY
READ MY BOOK ON THE PLOT TO
DESTROY THE PRESIDENT, WHICH IS
IN FACT ABOUT THE CONSPIRACY --
THE FIRST IN AMERICAN HISTORY
SINCE 1783 AND THE NEWBURGH
CONSPIRACY THAT TRIED TO
OVERTHROW A SITTING PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: WHY DID THEY ASK
YOU ABOUT ROGER STONE?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
I'VE MET ROGER STONE THREE TIMES
I'VE MET ROGER STONE THREE TIME
TIMES.
HE DID WRITE THE FORWARD TO MY
NEW BOOK BECAUSE WE HAD THE SAME
PUBLISHER.
HE GAVE AN ADDRESS AT
OXFORD UNIVERSITY ABOUT EIGHT OR
TEN WEEKS AGO AND IT WAS A
PRETTY COMPELLING STORY ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE 2016
ELECTION AND WE HAD IT
TRANSCRIBED.
I HAD ATTENDED THAT LECTURE, AND
WE USED IT AS THE FORWARD TO THE
BOOK.
MAYBE THEY READ MORE INTO THAT
THEN IS THE CASE.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID THEY DO TO
YOUR PHONE?
YOU SAID THEY HAD A WARRANT FOR
>> YES.
THEY CONFISCATED MY PHONE AND
I'M TOLD IT'S BEEN RETURNED TO
ME AND I SHOULD BE RECEIVING IT
ANY DAY.
>> Tucker: THEY TOOK YOUR
PHONE AWAY?
HOW LONG HAVE THEY HAD IT?
>> SINCE THAT DAY, WHICH WAS
BEFORE EASTER.
>> Tucker: I WOULD BE PRETTY